one remote from from TBS that I got to
work on it was not my idea was Conan's
idea was when we went to London and shot
it with Tom Cruise oh great yeah but
Conan had an idea that uh that he
pitched to Tom Cruise which is
um
well exactly basically basically so the
idea is Tom Cruise gets in the car with
Conan and notices cameras and says uh
wow oh I see I see what we're gonna do
we're going to do karaoke this is gonna
be really fun Cody says no no no no no
that's not what I had in mind and then
Tom goes well you know I see I know what
we're gonna do we're going to talk about
comedy and go get coffee right right
we're in the car and Conan says no
everyone else has done bells and
whistles they get in the car and they do
something yeah it was fun okay it's fun
fun yeah but okay cool that's cool sure
but my thing Tom yeah because my thing
is we take it back to basics okay Basics
good we take it back to basics let's
listen to this yeah
we just drive
interesting mind blower right and it's
just quietly the car starts to pull away
and Tom Cruise I have to say he's great
he was so funny yeah and he just is like
so we're just gonna
we're just gonna go for a drive and
Conan just says it's gonna go for a
drive
and they just sat there and quietly
drove through London
[Applause]
and Tom would Point things out Tom would
try to hey
Thames is the Tower of London and
Koenigsegg Tom Tom
I'm trying to just kind of focus on
driving
it was that's a funny idea to take the
biggest star in the world you're telling
him to shut up he drives quietly for 11.
for 11 minutes and Tom Cruise had Great
Moments improvising he was he would be
like uh I wouldn't mind uh using the
bathroom pardon me I wouldn't mind using
that I'm gonna use a bathroom
I could you know what it's actually
why keep this
this works great I'm gonna have to stop
you know it's something I had in mind it
also looks a little used there
so this is going to work for a system
cheats that's not what I had in mind
this is not what you had it's just no
but thank you coming in thank you very
much she came prepared I got you covered
and then another another thing that Tom
Cruise improvised was he he takes out
his cell phone and he and he's he's
turning away from Conan he's calling you
hey it's me
um he's just driving
just find us come get me and he's
improvising with you know as a manager
or something like that he did all of
that he was really really no that was
him he was really funny he totally got
it perfectly that was so brilliant
because didn't Tom Cruise also have a
broken leg so he had a broken leg a
little bit of a necessity exactly
because he was filming Mission
Impossible and he had broken his leg
Yeah so we had to think of something it
was Conan's idea something they can do
sitting down and we had to put a
disclaimer on that because people
thought Conan had kidnapped had
kidnapped him it was that realistic and
then we had one the Ender is Tom Cruise
rolls out of the car right yeah and we
had a stunt guy that was going to do the
actual role because Tom Cruise had a
broken leg but so we said to him you
know if you want if you can just reach
for the door handle and open the door
we'll film you from behind and we'll cut
he
he reaches for the door handle and
flings the door open and I mean hangs
out the car and almost touches the road
what is the one like if you push that
button yeah which
[Applause]
it paid for all of his Christmas cakes